et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Jean-Philippe Tanguy bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous députés
rassemblements national de la somme on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Fabrice wesser
Redon du groupe Ebra bonjour Fabrice
bonjourno de l'Est de la France on
commence évidemment par la réforme des
retraites Elisabeth band reste donc
ferme le report de l'âge légal de départ
64 ans n'est plus négociable est-ce que
vous pensez vraiment pouvoir empêcher
cette réforme de passer oui mais là où
Madame borne est hypocrite comme
d'habitude c'est que ça n'a jamais été
négociable en fait il y a jamais eu
vraiment eu de discussion depuis le
début madame borne et là pour appliquer
la feuille de route de Monsieur Macron
elle a reçu les organisations syndicales
mais ne les ai jamais écoutés ou tenter
de créer un compromis donc de toute
façon la population française ne veut
pas de ce 64 ans donc on va s'y opposer
au Parlement par tous les moyens
possibles il me semble objectivement que
la meilleure façon c'est de voter la
motion référendaire pour de renvoyer
renvoyer cette loi devant le peuple on
va y venir la
minutes avant ils veulent savoir si oui
ou non il y aura référendum donc nous on
a une liberté qui nous permet justement
de pas faire de politique politicienne
et on votera la motion référendaire même
si elle est venue des communistes donc
on soit clair vous votez la voiture
référendaire oui communiste de la nuque
et il y a pas de motion référendaire du
rassemblement national non mais c'est la
règlement de l'Assemblée si vous voulez
mais ce qui compte là mais sauf que vous
vouliez en déposer une jeune fille
Marine Le Pen l'a annoncé
ça amuse la nupesse de faire des petits
coups en passant 5 minutes avant un
député RN tant mieux pour eux nous les
Français savent parce que quand ça fait
6 mois que on vote les textes sur le
fond la nupette qu'on propose quelque
chose qu'il propose il ne vote pas par
exemple le droit de visite le droit de
visite dans les EHPAD c'est quand même
pas politiquement clivant d'autoriser
les députés aller visiter les EHPAD bon
et bah la nuit peste ne l'a pas voté en
disant comme c'est le RN qui propose on
ne vote pas donc ce sont des enfants
c'est niveau de bac à sable nous le
référendum qu'ils viennent de n'importe
quelle partie on le soutiendra toujours
mais est-ce que ça n'illustre pas le
fait que la gauche est plus audible que
vous dans l'opposition à ce texte
maintenant
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est pas l'échec de votre
stratégie d'avoir perdu une élection
partielle bah non si vous voulez quand
vous avez la nupestre qui fait appelé à
voter pour une candidate qui soutient la
réforme des retraites c'est la nups qui
est ridicule voilà la sociologie de race
vous savez en seulement 6 mois on a
gagné en juin elle a gagné contre la NPS
elle a elle a l'élection été annulée
parce que la candidate macroniste avait
tricher et maintenant la nupes qui a été
éliminée au premier tour avec une
candidate qui avait gagné 12 points a
finalement fait appelé à la battre au
deuxième tour voilà bon ça fait quand
même que le RN a gagné 8 points à Reims
en 6 mois oui mais votre candidate a
perdu face à quelqu'un de la majorité
présidentielle et grâce à la nupesse
mais enfin à cause
Gérald Gérald Darmanin ce weekend
parlait aussi que la nuit pêche et la
France insoumise en accusant et les
filles et les amis de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
de vouloir bordéliser le pays vous
partagez l'analyse de Gérard Darmanin
écoutez oui la nuit pèse le veut mais
pour le moment il faut le dire les
syndicats n'ont pas du tout cette
stratégie
la manifestation pardon de la semaine
dernière s'est passé dans le calme comme
d'ailleurs elle devrait toujours se
passer donc oui c'est sans doute que la
nuit pèse elle voudrait effectivement
faire de la récupération politique du
mouvement syndical ce n'est pas le cas
donc il faut il faut le saluer il faut
espérer que ça se passe encore très bien
mardi il y a pas de raison à partir du
moment où l'ordre et bien tenu à Paris
il faut dire que le changement de préfet
a l'air quand même de bonne augure et
que le comportement du préfet très
différent de celui d'avant et ensuite
les syndicats font leur travail et vous
vous exprimez complètement de descendre
manifester il y aura aucun membre du
rassemblement national dans la rue
demain
ou des élus des députés non je ne pense
pas mais en tout cas c'est pas ma
culture d'aller manifester avec les
syndicats bon voilà mais ça veut pas
dire j'ai parfois j'ai eu beaucoup de de
fausses informations là dessus on n'a
pas dit qu'il fallait pas les manifester
on a dit que la place des députés
c'était au Parlement après moi je vous
dis dans la Somme j'ai voté tes
adhérents des sympathisants des gens qui
sont venus samedi j'ai fait philosophe
et permanence qui vont aller manifester
mais c'est place des députés pour vous
c'est pas la place des députés il y a un
compromis en France on a une culture
politique qui est ancienne Peugeot le
disent il y a la séparation stricte de
l'action syndicale de l'action politique
c'est pas le cas dans tous les pays et
je pense que les syndicats n'ont pas
envie d'avoir des des partis politiques
qui viennent récupérer leur action et
des personnes qui viennent manipuler
pour vous oui mais toujours mais
toujours façon ils sont toujours
perpétuellement dans la récupération et
si possible dans le pourrissement des
conflits sociaux s'ouvre-nous des gilets
jaunes si les gilets jaunes
malheureusement sont parfois partis dans
certaines dérives c'est à cause de la
nuit parfois de la nups de l'époque
est-ce que vous encouragez les salariés
à me faire des mouvements de grève
reconductibles mais moi j'ai pas
encouragé les les salariés si vous
voulez une fois de plus moi je crois à
la différenciation entre l'action
syndicale qui doit rassembler des gens
qui votent pour tous les partis et les
partis politiques si on commence à se
mêler de l'action syndicale l'action
syndicale est perd de son sens donc vous
savez nous Marine Le Pen a souvent dit
on a des principes auxquels on se tient
même quand ils nous sont peut-être déf
politiquement donc on a toujours été
pour la séparation du mouvement social
quel qu'il soit et de la politique donc
on va pas changer d'avis uniquement pour
faire quelques voix mais là ça vous
dessert politiquement de ne pas pouvoir
vous associer à cette conférence je
crois que les Français sont attachés à
ces différenciation les maires du est-ce
que les maires du rassemblement national
puisqu'il y a des mers du rassemblement
national suivront l'appel lancée par
Fabien Roussel qui appelle les maires à
fermer symboliquement leur mairie demain
non mais là vous voulez la note un
comportement qui n'est pas républicain
la mairie c'est un service public qui
est ouvert à tous les citoyens quel que
soit leur opinion si vous êtes un
citoyen avec révolté pour Monsieur
Macron et qui a besoin d'aller à la
mairie vous devez pouvoir y aller de la
même manière qu'il doit y avoir un
service minimum dans des services
publics vitaux comme l'hôpital imaginez
demain directeur d'hôpital qui dit bah
moi je ferme l'hôpital parce que je suis
pas d'accord avec la réforme
minimum ne sera pas assuré dans la merde
pour vous c'est anti républicain ce que
ça s'appelle des familles quand il est
élu il est élu de tous les habitants un
député quand il est élu tous les
habitants monsieur Macron qui l'oublie
souvent est élu de tous les Français
voilà donc il faut que les hommes
politiques sachent faire la différence
entre leur convictions personnelles leur
combat politique qui sont nobles
légitimes même quand je les partage pas
et leur mandat républicain qui doit être
toujours au service de toute la
population y compris des gens avec qui
ne sont pas d'accord justement puisque
on parle de la stratégie au Parlement
puisque c'est celle que vous avez choisi
le gouvernement a choisi de passer par
le 47 ans ça limite la durée des débats
Fabien Roussel a encore lui demande à
Yelle brune Pivet la présidente de
l'Assemblée que l'article qui reporte
l'âge de départ soit examiné en priorité
c'est une demande à laquelle vous
souscrivez c'est nous qui l'avons
demandé c'est mes collègues toi aménagés
et leur La Valette à la commission des
affaires sociales qu'on fait une lettre
officielle vendredi matin on est en
commission finance à ce moment-là
j'interpellais mes collègues de la
France de la nupes pour savoir s'ils
avaient soutenir cette demande où il est
vrai qu'elle communiste n'était pas là
je pense qu'ils vont la soutenir donc
voilà et ils vont faire croire que c'est
eux quoi vous avez passé une demande de
Fabien Rousselière vous avez une réponse
de dial brochet pas encore la lettre a
été faite vendredi donc j'imagine que la
présidente la consultera ce matin il y a
des questions qui se posent de la part
des oppositions sur le fait le choix du
gouvernement d'être passé par ce 47 ans
est-ce que vous pourriez saisir le
Conseil constitutionnel à ce sujet
écoutez pour tout vous dire oui j'ai
demandé de une note à des conseillers
d'État sur ce sujet je vais la recevoir
et je pense qu'on en tirera les
conséquences car oui effectivement c'est
une procédure étrange pour étudier une
loi aussi importante qui nécessite du
temps mais tout cela sera réglé si tout
le monde arrive à se mettre d'accord sur
la motion référendaire on en revient là
parce que vous savez on peut discuter
tout ce qu'on veut je pense que la seule
façon de faire c'est soit d'affaiblir le
consensus et les républicains pour qu'il
ne votent pas la réforme ce qui est
possible et ce qui est de plus en plus
le cas visiblement soit de la renvoyer
vers référendum sinon ils appellent 49,3
vous appelez les républicains à voter
cette notion infernale ah oui oui
j'espère qu'il vautrons la motion
référendaire parce qu'il se réclame du
souvent comme votre serviteur bon quand
le sens du référendum dans la Cinquième
République c'est que quand il y a un
blocage ce qui est le cas quand il y a
un conflit de légitimité entre d'une
part monsieur Macron qui a été élu
notamment grâce à la nups et les députés
qui ont été élus sur un autre mandat le
seul façon de régler le conflit
légitimité dans la République c'est
référendum
le
Mans et Parlement puisque vous contestez
le choix de ce 47 ans pourquoi vous avez
refusé que le Parti socialiste reporte
sa journée d'initiative ce qui aurait
laissé un jour de plus de débat à
l'Assemblée nationale parce que les
textes étaient prêts et qui ont nous
semblait qu'il fallait les étudier ce
jour-là et enfin eux-mêmes étaient prêts
aller décaler oui mais il y a un travail
ils ont demandé un report ça aurait
laissé plus de 10 heures supplémentaires
de débat une fois plus on en revient à
ce que je vous ai on va pas être à 10
heures de débat c'est à dire que soit il
y a un englisement du débat parce que
les insoumis enfin la nupesse a déposé
5000 amendements soit il y a pas
d'ennuisement du débat mais faire croire
que c'est avec Deezer qu'on va changer
la nature du débat là c'est encore un
mensonge et c'est de l'agritation en
fait la nuit pêche regrette c'est un peu
contradictoire
de débat à l'Assemblée nationale et là
on vous propose une journée de plus et
vous rejetez ça non on nous l'a pas
proposé une journée en plus vous avez
refusé que le PS décale sa journée a
voulu faire une manœuvre pour faire
oublier le fait qu'ils ont choisi de
déposer 5000 à 90 pour insoumis et les
autres encore plus ce qui fait de toute
façon on ne peut pas on n'est pas dans
Samuel le moment excusez-moi on ne peut
pas tenir le débat donc comme ils savent
qu'ils ont fait de bêtises parce qu'en
fait ils le regrette et qui veulent
revenir à des discussions plus sérieuses
maintenant ils essaient de faire porter
la responsabilité sur la semelle et les
autres parce que c'est pas que nous qui
pouvons bloquer un changement de jour
vous le savez très bien donc ils ont
fait ce choix de faire de l'obstruction
maintenant qu'il se rendent compte que
l'obstruction est contre-productive ils
essaient de nous faire passer le bébé
donc c'est un peu gros et je pense que
personne n'est dû en tout cas pas moi on
va parler du fond du texte oui quel
projet vous allez porter avec quel
financement quel est l'idée l'idée c'est
que en fait l'acte de départ à la
retraite dépend de votre âge d'entrée
dans le monde du travail c'est beaucoup
plus juste lorsqu'on compte qu'avec la
réforme les personnes de Monsieur Macron
les personnes qui ont commencé entre 20
et 22 ans vont cotiser 44 ans et non pas
43 ans comme la pose la loi nous c'est
très simple si vous avez commencé à
travailler pardon avant 20 ans vous
partez à 60 ans et quand vous avez
commencé à travailler entre 20 ans et 22
ans vous partez à 62 ans et après c'est
limité à 62 ans donc en fait ça limite
quel que soit votre métier quel que soit
votre carrière la durée de cotisation à
42 ans maximum en fait la durée de
cotisation pour nous est plus importante
presque que l'âge de départ à la
retraite puisque ça permet de mettre de
la justice sociale parce qu'on considère
pour éviter les critères compliqués
auxquels personne ne comprend rien que
quand on a commencé à travailler tôt ce
sont souvent des métiers plus difficiles
donc ça intègre la pénibilité de facto
les républicains ont voté un amendement
qui va un petit peu dans ce sens
puisqu'ils disent pour les gens qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 21 ans il
faut que ce soit les 43 annuités qui
priment et pas du tout l'âge légal de
départ vous pourriez voter cet
amendement oui je crois que d'ailleurs
qu'on a déposé un dans lequel même sens
pour limiter les dégâts mais enfin 43
ans c'est quand même un an de plus que
42 ans donc nous on limitera à 42 sur la
réforme Touraine
c'était la promesse de Marine Le Pen où
on revient sur la réforme Touraine la
réforme socialiste Touraine d'ailleurs
ça permet de rappeler que c'était une
réforme demande de la nups donc
rappelons quand même que la coalition
des membres de la coalition du Pesse ont
augmenté la durée de cotisation faut le
rappeler parce que quand les écoute la
mémoire courte donc sur l'âge de départ
vous allez défendre un légal de départ
différencié en fonction du mot
exactement
sur le marché du travail juste un mot
sur l'index senior est-ce que ça c'est
une bonne chose pour vous
en soit savoir combien il y a de seniors
qui travaillent dans une entreprise ça
permet de faire le point et après
d'apprendre des mesures mais faut pas
croire que c'est parce qu'il y a un
index qui va y avoir des solutions voilà
par exemple pour l'intégration d'autres
catégories de population il y avait
toujours eu des pénalités vous êtes
favorable à la mise en place de
pénalités de sanctions à l'égal des
entreprises il faut l'étudier de façon
précise parce que ça dépend les
entreprises vous avez des entreprises ou
leur activité fait qu'il est difficile
d'avoir des seniors par exemple
une seule phrase voilà c'était avec la
pénalité plus selon certains critères
donc ça devient très compliqué
de sanction oui parce que c'est facile
oui c'est facile pour s'en sortir de
dire oui on va pénaliser moi je crois
dialogue social il y a des il y a des
comme des syndicats il y a des
représentants des salariés je pense
qu'on peut trouver des solutions avant
toujours d'aller dans le dans la pub
dans la punition dans la pénalité bon
notamment pour les TPE PME si vous
voulez c'est pas forcément facile de
prendre des pénalités parce que vous
avez pas respecté une loi qui vient de
Paris donc mettons les choses un peu
calmement et trouvons des solutions soit
pas pourquoi les entreprises ont pas
envie par définition de mal se comporter
force de leur un peu confiance si on
fait une fois plus confiance au dialogue
social c'est ça qu'il faut renforcer un
dernier mot vous n'allez rien voter sur
ce texte il y a rien pour vous dans
cette réforme de retraite parce qu'il y
a des mesures sociales aussi oui bah si
moi on a déjà annoncé qu'on voterait le
fait que la pension minimum soit à 80%
du SMIC on on l'a toujours proposé mais
on rappelle que c'était une vieille
promesse c'est voilà c'est une loi qui
se balade depuis le début des années
2000 2003 je crois
par les finances puisque c'est un sujet
que vous suivez à l'Assemblée
milliards de 3 milliards de dettes pour
la pour le pays est-ce que du coup votre
proposition sur les retraites elle est
elle est tenable économiquement pour un
pays comme la nôtre oui et les tenable
parce que vous savez les gouvernements
qui succèdent et moi malheureusement ma
génération entière l'inconnu ne font que
gérer la pénurie mais c'est la pénurie
qu'ils ont eux-mêmes organisé en perdant
notre industrie en affaiblissant notre
agriculture nous avons perdu notre
productivité nous avons perdu notre
capacité à créer de la richesse or pour
que notre système tienne il faut bien
créer de la richesse par exemple on a
perdu vous vous rendez compte 10 points
de PIB de PIB industriel depuis 30 ans
et aujourd'hui le gouvernement prévoit
rien parce que quand ils font des
grandes annonces de réinitialisation
vous savez on a voté aussi la loi sur
l'énergie bon l'industrie c'est
l'énergie il faut de l'électricité pour
faire tourner vos usines bon bah eux ils
ont prévu que l'industrie resterait
seulement à 10% du PIB dans 30 ans donc
en fait le gouvernement n'a aucun plan
pour réindustrialiser pareil pour la
natalité si vous voulez un système des
retraites par répartition il faut
relancer la natalité qu'est-ce qui est
prévu dans la loi rien du tout et la
natalité continue à baisser donc moi je
suis pas dans la question de la pénurie
je suis dans le Progrès natalité
l'universalité des allocations
familiales améliorer encore pour
notamment les femmes qui veulent
conjuguer leur vie de famille et leur
vie professionnelle notamment un service
public de l'accueil de la petite enfance
améliorer une fois plus égalitaire aux
femmes au travail il y a plein de façons
de relancer
il faut il faut c'est pas moi qui vais
dire il faut mais il faut mettre en
place le cadre oui oui
cela soit fait pardon vous savez la
France a été pendant longtemps le pays
européen avec la plus forte natalité
surtout de natalité au-dessus de deux
c'est-à-dire le renouvellement des
enfants et toutes les études montrent
aujourd'hui que les femmes françaises en
moyenne voudraient faire un enfant de
plus que ce qu'elles ont aujourd'hui
c'est bien qu'il y a un blocage un
blocage économique un blocage
professionnel on va parler d'un autre
texte c'est le projet de l'immigration
qui sera présenté en Conseil des
ministres mercredi auxquels le
rassemblement national s'oppose alors
pour prendre les mots de Gérald Darmanin
hier dans le Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France ce texte permet je le sais
d'expulser encore plus d'étrangers
délinquants sans leur trouver d'excuses
juridique de mettre fin à la fin de la
double peine de conditionner les titres
de séjour à la réussite d'un examen de
Londres de langue vous êtes contre ces
mesures mais sur le papier moi je
comprends que les gens se disent
beaucoup on est contre mais c'est des
mesures qui soient existent déjà soit
déjà été annoncées si vous suit l'examen
de langue ça déjà été fait appliqué dans
700 fois mais ça déjà été annoncé que je
me souviens c'est à l'époque c'était le
gouvernement de Monsieur Villepinte
monsieur Fillon à chaque fois on fait
ses annonces là ça n'est pas tenu parce
que l'examen ça dépend ce qu'il y a dans
l'examen vous pouvez annoncer un examen
si l'examen est bidon comme il est
depuis 10 ans pardon 15 ans et ben ce
sera ça restera du bidon la question
c'est qu'en fait ils se veulent tout
faire pour continuer à accueillir plus
d'immigrations et rendre légal une
filière qui aujourd'hui illégale
c'est-à-dire d'arriver de manière
illégale clandestine sur le territoire
et de commencer à travailler mais là
vous voyez bien il y a des mesures plus
drastiques pour pourquoi vous les
refusez refusez les mesures parce que
vous dites peut-être qu'elles sont pas
tenues c'est qu'on a un peu d'expérience
sur la gestion ou la non gestion des
flux migratoires par les gouvernements
successifs la semaine dernière ça vous a
pas échappé a été annoncé un nouveau
record d'entrée légale pas de
clandestins d'entrée légale à 350 000 à
350 000 entrées bon l'année où Monsieur
Darmanin va annoncé plus de fermeté
et de la fin des dérives donc en fait
ils veulent tout simplement créer de
nouvelles filières d'immigration parce
qu'en fait le droit de venir travailler
pour les clandestins c'est une nouvelle
filière d'immigration donc ça va juste
transformer des clans destins en immigré
légaux mais ça restera
provisoires conditionnés à des années de
séjour dans le pays oui et à travailler
bon vous aujourd'hui
le taux de chômage des immigrés et le
double des Français donc on n'a pas
besoin de gens qui travaillent déjà en
emploi mais on peut faire travailler les
gens qui sont déjà sur place vous savez
et vous avez 30 milliards d'euros par
par an pour la formation on va cet
argent les tensions dans les tensions
dans le BTP
mais oui mais c'est bien ce que je vous
dis c'est pas le premier employeur c'est
le problème que l'argent de la formation
en France est mal utilisé que le régime
social est mal conditionné et du fait
qu'on est effectivement un taux de
chômage très important en particulier
chez les immigrés qui n'est pas résolu
depuis des années moi je suis désolé
madame ça fait la moitié de ma vie
maintenant que j'entends qu'il y a des
tensions dans la restauration quand
j'étais serveur il y avait déjà des
tensions dans la restauration il y a
toujours eu des tensions dans le BTP
donc ce sont pas des crises anciennes ce
sont des crises qui se sont aggravées
donc quel que soit les la teneur du
débat parlementaire vous serez que votre
réponse de ce texte oui mais il y a pas
d'ouverture possible pour moi mais on
peut voter par exemple le fait de
retirer un certain nombre de motifs de
contestation d'une expulsion ça on peut
le voter mais ce sont des petites
mesures par rapport à l'enjeu qui est de
retrouver le contrôle de nos frontières
et donc le contrôle de l'immigration il
est également ouvert à des quotas pour
limiter les régularités les
régularisations pardon est-ce que ça
vous pourriez le soutenir non mais
pareil
franchement chaque année vous vous
faites votre métier depuis un certain
nombre d'années la question des quotas
c'est c'est l'arlésienne ça revient tout
le temps pas plus les quotas ça consiste
à légaliser une filière d'immigration en
lui donnant un nouveau mot un dernier
mot là-dessus puisqu'il y a dans le dans
cette interview Gérald Darmanin dit je
le cite Madame Le Pen travaille peu et
s'oppose à tout elle est d'accord avec
tous ceux qui sont contre cela fait sans
doute de bons sondages mais pas une
femme d'État que répondez-vous ça c'est
la mise au génie crasse pour pas dire
autre chose de Monsieur de La misogyne
oui c'est-à-dire considérer que Madame
Le Pen ne travaille pas en assistant
bien sur Madame et parce que vous parce
que c'est le Tonk c'est employé vous
avez déjà entendu dire à ça pour un
homme régulièrement donnez-moi un
exemple bah il se prive pas d'attaquer
aujourd'hui Mélenchon travaillait pas
peut-être pas dans ces mots mais là quel
est le rapport avec le fait que ce soit
une femme exactement il se prive pas
d'attaquer d'autres adversaires
maintenant c'est sa spécialité
d'ailleurs y compris avec des concerts à
vous journaliste voilà c'est sa
spécialité de toujours attaquer les
opposants qu'il dérange sous la ceinture
et en particulier la crédibilité des
femmes il fait ça si
ça m'a effectivement beaucoup énervé
parce que Monsieur Darmanin depuis un
certain temps un espèce de blanc sein
pour se comporter très mal en
particulier avec les femmes politiques
mais pas seulement avec les journalistes
avec un certain nombre de personnes donc
le méprime monsieur Darmanin il peut le
sauvegarder et il devrait commencer à
travailler lui-même parce que quand on
est capable de laisser monsieur une
partie le jour où on a tout le Conseil
des tarent en arrêt pour l'expulser il
devrait mieux se regarder dans un miroir
et de la même façon la gestion du Stade
de France quand on était capable de dire
aux Français droit dans les yeux que
c'était des oliganes Anglais qui avait
dépouillé les spectateurs alors que tout
le monde sait que c'est pas le cas et
qu'il a menti non seulement en français
me reste du monde il ferait mieux une
fois plus de se regarder dans un miroir
il se rendra compte que c'est pas
terrible allez dernière question
politique sur l'organisation de votre
frange politique Nicolas Dupont-Aignan
votre ancien patron veut une coalition
des patriotes avec Le Pen fil la salle
on ferait notamment vous en pensez quoi
ah bah c'est très bien mais moi je n'ai
pas d'hostilité envers Nicolas dupoignon
qui a un homme courageux donc moi vous
êtes toujours en contact avec lui mais
il y a pas de problème moi je suis allé
d'ailleurs si j'ai rejoint Madame Le Pen
aux régionales de 2020 2021 pardon c'est
justement parce que je pensais qu'il
fallait cette coalition à l'époque il
pensait que c'était trop tôt c'est sa
liberté donc si on se retrouve sur le
rassemblement de toutes les bugs les
bonnes volontés pour proposer autre
chose au français moi je suis ravi
merci Fabrice et merci Jean-Philippe
Tanguy d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
merci bonne journée à vous face au club
des territoires